the contest is hotting up and the field
has been whittled down one blonde
bombshell remains the front-runner and
these are the politicians who've made it
through to the next round of the
Conservative Party's game of knockout or
should it be called the contest for who
gets to lose - Boris Johnson in the race
for Downing Street the quest for a new
leader has got the country pouring over
their contestants of dirty laundry
Gordon Brown as Prime Minister would be
utterly outrageous not just because he's
a gloom Adhan popping interfering
high-tax in complicated of life but
mainly because he's a Scots and
government by a Scot is just not
conceivable in the current
constitutional context - Brian you say
that the man that you're backing Jeremy
cut I'm so sorry Jeremy Hunt I've never
said that before in my life it's usually
men who say that so I really really want
to apologize I'm sorry can you guess
which politician took which drug in
their pre politics days Michael Gove was
a front-runner but his campaign was
marred after he was forced to admit he
dabbled with cocaine in the 1990s it was
a crime it was a mistake I deeply regret
it should you have gone to prison well I
was I was fortunate in that I didn't and
then there's Rory Stewart he started as
the rank outsider his warts-and-all
media strategy hashtag Rory walks has
been gathering momentum up until now the
Secretary of State for international
development
wasn't that well-known outside of
Westminster or isn't good
hi are you happy to have a cook film for
I'm filming something I'm a politician
and standing to be Prime Minister so I'm
going around meeting people okay I want
to see what people are up to with all
this dirt on offer you'd expect those
competing for a chance to move in here
in a couple of weeks time to engage in
some good old-fashioned political
mudslinging but at this stage of the
contest Boris Johnson is so far ahead
that the other conservative candidates
appear to have come down with a case of
politeness perhaps looking into the
future and vying for top positions in an
all but inevitable Boris Johnson cabinet
you